comme ils disaient qu'ils ne tireraient
pas
rigueur
choristes de jusqu'à quand institutrice
anny grondin possède de multiples cordes
à son arc
depuis quelques années elle consacre une
grande partie de son temps à raconter
des histoires des contes créoles enfui
dans nos mémoires elle a su les remettre
au goût du jour et transmettre une
tradition quelque peu oublier une
véritable passion née de sa plus tendre
enfance
il vient comme un des petits n'est venu
ma vie me line d'enlever en place dans
le cadre de beaufonds mille veut dire
dans le cadre de l' usine où ça tout le
temps tout en ôtant terracotta nos
histoires comme tu es mon de la plaine
changement des nvidia ou parce que mon
histoire il fallait à tout prix raconté
après six heures soit sinon transforme
en crapaud et bonne histoire fallait
surtout pas à contacter inquiète
beaucoup amusé de sinnoh ben nous avons
mauvaisin mettra pas aux dons femmes et
vidéo commenté tim payne adam et me
rappelle quand il fait clair à l'appel
la est tombée comme souvent
notifiés aime la provoc notifiait ma
fenêtre comme certifie mois où était gay
raconte distance
avec ma grande joie c'est que me
racontent devant le monde et
notamment nous on a des sciences
maintenant le mercredi au niveau des
médiathèques qui prend un petit peu le
relais de ses espaces muséaux qui dit
qu'ils partaient et donc avec la en ce
moment ne fait donc à médiathèque de
sainte marie donc on a un rendez vous
régulier depuis deux ans maintenant
c'est le troisième mercredi du mois donc
ou bien c'est la médiathèque de san
marino sinon dans les hauts de sainte
marie et là vraiment c'est encore une
autre aventure parce que bon ça va dans
des lieux qu'on ne connaissait pas du
tout où les hauts de sainte marie kuhn a
dit marmaille pinana 10 adultes manade
autres mounia vivent grâce aux 6 et
c'est encore une autre façon mais pense
que de retransmettre ce bandit storti
gens que tu vraiment et fument presque
presque oublié
moi mais c'est retransmettent aussi les
histoires comme moi marc avait valu est
le vrai que quand on est petit on
entende le banc d'histoire c'est mais
rappelle moi c'est des moments de mes
deux peuples mais terrible quand même
avec le mode histoire vous connaissez
des histoires c'est pas vrai mais amy
veut dire le compte pas les grands dia
est tout même aimait bien bien joué bien
bien joué avec ses sentiments là et me
pense que au niveau de deux bonnes
normal il faut ça il faut que tu n'as
peut il faut que la peur il faut il faut
qu'on arrive à transmettre ça mais il
faut aussi odieuse écoute ça c'est
vraiment des cper des pubs des histoires
aussi est bon il est vrai que comme
miley petit fait pas le pas entre le
réel et l'imaginaire est normal mais
après quand aux tigres en dise les pays
grandit zotti bisotti grandi avec et
puis on arrive à faire la part des
choses
c'est légal m je sais que nana toute une
tranche de deux marmailles par exemple
des adolescents n'ont pas là du tout
avec le baliste on sait ce qui dit
d'habitude mais mal à une expérience
dernièrement avec bane marmaille collège
bras panon parce que bon au niveau des
interventions me fait aussi deux
d'intervention que de raconter et l'a
été moins bon il faut qu intervient avec
bane marmailles dans de grands marmaille
même âge que maya comme jean maillet
avec son casque eric cossa me savais pas
ce mode histoire ti-jean avec mme normal
pas besoin au bout de deux séances mais
vraiment des trucs mais très très
difficile des fois ils passaient pas du
tout
fm monde
hunan à la magie de l'histoire les
histoires parce
que c'est pas toujours le plus que
d'enfants c'est là aussi des adultes qui
viennent qui est cotée qui sont très
contents de rang et goûter un peu ces
histoires oubliées malheureusement et
c'est de bien c'est justement les
parents il vient donc donc du moment
quotidien soit les faits les parents
directs ou les grands parents désolé
concernés aimez vous diront enfin il
coupa le relais transmission de
deux lames ou moins qu'on fait et donc
la dot n'a d'autres religions met en
place et c'est ça que les biens et vos
enfants à vos est ce qu il vienne nous
accompagne ah oui total ban a dit woods
a grandi d'un petit jean dans diable
qu'on est à calais tout
jusqu'au cou bon maintenant c'est une
grand
midi pas besoin n'est pas intéressé
parce que à chaque fois qu'il parle de
compter tous les vrais que ce qui prend
la peine de regarder ce qui connaît les
grands classiques disons de grandir avec
toutes les variantes et ça m'émeut des
os et m'a vraiment ma grande joie que de
dire qu'on met mes enfants n'a pas loupé
ce à quoi
tu travailles avec les enfants annie
depuis combien de temps
elle fait le disant à peu près il n'y
avait que donc mais fait l'école
pareillement retourner sur saint benoît
bras fusil et l'appareil fait il fait
cinq six ans on est sur le quartier de
bahan fusil en fait c'est un coup de
même bien parce que bon c'est bon
d'abord saint benoît la côte et de
beaufonds moi-même et demain à grondines
bouffon dans un tamis dim à l'esprit bof
on y monte
comblée dans l'école ou malades et des
règles donc seulement my
le fait n'importe quoi en fait ça n'a
fait que me tous les repas et mal est
vraiment très très exigeante sur les
règles comme avec les mémés marmaille
amant pareil comme il veut dire où il
veut dire être en permanence il laisse
pas passer simon wright pas bonjour
amine s'il dit pas mais à six il dit pas
s'il vous plaît on est peut-être vieux
jeu mais peut-être
mais peut-être
les petites pas nécessaire mais ça c'est
ma fille a clairement que me tient
énormément et en fin de compte il n'y
arrive quand même à avoir bondi de
grande satisfaction parce que là aussi
dans la classe mais veut dire humana 2
essaye vraiment faire passer 7 7 mm
à lorgues en diable à face en hausse et
le premier de la collection prêt qui
craquait oui voilà alors les histoires
les histoires ti-jean ça c'est un levier
histoire mais vous diront vraiment c'est
les histoires que l'est le plus présent
dans ma mémoire en fait que quand il
était petit
et donc c'est un projet qui dieu depuis
20 ans parce que n'avait-on m'a dit 'si
nous gagne sauf un histoire ti-jean
c'est celle là qu'il faut sauver
n'est donc pas un texte en créole un
texte en français
parce que c'est un aspect qui tiendra
comme il veut dire 'oui' mais trouve que
l'intérêt justement au niveau de créole
macho bataille pour que le créole est
reconnue comme une langue à part entière
le fait que miffy l'école si médias
moment donné il faudrait que nous arrive
à peut-être inverser les relations entre
le créole et le français à savoir
peut-être maintenant enfin comme il a
peut-être des noirs arrivent à cause
mieux français et alliés priol le fait
qu'il fait l'école va mal on n est pas
qu aux français et me dit que les
dommages quoi il faut ajouter une arrive
à cause français a regagné bien inscrit
man ou quoi et ça n'empêche pas le fait
que nous construirons n'empêche pas que
le fait que nous cognos annulés qui ça
nous laisse où ça ne sortait toumi
l'audio est donc vraiment ça cesse
hanafi qui tiendra vraiment très très à
coeur de faire de maître vraiment les
deux ans au même niveau et là tu donc
n'aura le texte écrit en créole et en
français il en a un cd dedans avec la
musique toujours gilbert mon dalon de
toujours mon compagnon de longue date
et nana haddock le cd ou nana la voie
avec une version en créole est une
version en français
ti jean grand diable la façon dont
en cette année 2010 a repris son rôle de
choristes avec disque à caen à
l'occasion du nouvel album 4 timo retour
aux sources retour à la scène avec toute
la famille cette fois
jb à athènes vient chanter dessus mon
dieu la grande joie totale donc moi
l'art aux embarquements en train de
chanter sur l'album avec my arms aux
enfants avec oasis mont garceau les deux
enfants toute l'équipe famille l'a fait
vraiment l entourage pintade dessus
la haie monde que la côte et moi c'est
ma maman
on profite de l'occasion c'est vraiment
elle l'image que me rends à un moment -
parce que les normales l affaire mois et
dans le livre d'ailleurs il demeure bien
tu premier a fait ses poumons moment-là
amène à moins d'un pays ici et ça n'est
pourtant pas ce que me dit vous choisi
par moments et ils ont bien fait les
moments il choisit pas les enfants mais
quand on a un enfant il collection x men
a même sensibilité quelques moments et
quand ils vous mange bien dans les deux
sens les extraordinaires et les superbes
parce que vraiment m'honorer n'aurait
pas été possible de faire tout ça si
elles n'étaient pas cotées pour pour
aider dans la vie de tous les jours
durant sur hbo il est bien beau raconte
l'histoire les biens boal eiffel fait
lever à cela ces indices cac confère
intéressante de ma fille bah écoute ou
l'est pas - mais veut dire ou es forme
voilà un métier à côté il veut dire que
mama il faut bouger vraiment dans le
quotidien
affirme en maille et qu'on en a beaucoup
en plus des artistes ma fille il veut
dire payer on connaissait le comblait
pas la vecquerie adeptes de connaître
chaque forme il met notre vie comme le
tien temps et ça m'a vraiment être très
très grand respect et une très grande
admiration pour bonne fin de la réunion
parce que je pense que bonne forme sur
ce bonne forme lama courage quand est ce
type au tout tout tout de suite dosé qui
portent
ils portent un paquet d'affaires et me
comprends aussi que la bonne forme qui
veut dire que des fois les fatiguer et
n'a pu le corps n'a plus le corps pour
vous prendre normal parce que la vie n'a
pas l'eau pas eu non plus mais vous
diront et la vie n'est pas tendre avec
bonne forme à la réunion est bon l'apa
le camp est née joly appelle demain
rigueur
m